Hendrick broke out of England Joon jet
broke out of England Stray Cats broke
out of England a lot of bands have had
to resort to going there cuz it's such a
force if you can make a noise there the
rest of the world pays attention you
know you'll set a trend over there yeah
we just had this immense popularity but
we couldn't get signed after being
rejected by every American label like
five times we went to England and got an
independent deal and we broke out of
England and when I remember coming back
to the States and kids going where's
your axe I thought you were English cuz
they first heard heard about us out of
England so yeah that was the breakout
but I just want to add that